hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Veronica
sixer we're gonna watch the trailer
today for a movie that's supposedly a
big [ __ ] deal
call into the woods know very little
about it I think it's a Disney musical
live adaptation live-action I think so
I think I'm not [ __ ] around this is
real and I know Meryl Streep's in it and
I know Johnny Depp's in it I like what
I'm hearing thus far other than that
no nothing so it makes us show great we
don't know anything we're gonna watch a
trailer and it has to sell us on all
right I'm excited for this let's do this
Thanks
Oh
ah Mikey was a meeting
we stir have the curse reversed
oh nice
happy
that looks awesome I have like serious
chills right now that movie looks really
[ __ ] good it I've seen three trailers
today and this by far is the best one
I've seen this looks really [ __ ] good
like that looks like a great time man
yeah just entertaining spectacle and you
got these great actors in it delivering
on all that be one thing if it was like
it's just Johnny Depp and then like no
one else is known but like to hear that
a lot of respectable people are on board
for this like Meryl Streep and uh you
mean Chris Pine eats the [ __ ] Johnny
Depp every time I see giant up in the
movie now so there's some weird thing
with him it's always like the first
thing
yeah the directing looks better because
I know that guy directed a couple
not-so-great movies after Chicago but he
don't like a good movie here and there
Rob Marshall so yeah I'm looking forward
to this big-time big-time and I know she
is - oh she loves these like do you ever
have like sexual fantasies where it's
like taking places like in those times
that realm I've never tried that you
should try it you should try it out
sometimes I imagine like I'm flying a
dragon and then I ride the dragon up and
then I saved the princess and then we
start [ __ ] on the dragon smaug that's
disrespectful how's that disrespectful
for the dragon [ __ ] he's burning up the
city and [ __ ] my dragons gonna be
destroying towns that's what I like
about my dragon I wish I had a dragon
like a real like like good me just like
a nice pretty dragon that
could kick ass but would also cuddle me
in the middle of night like under his
wing you want a puppy no puppy can't
protect me you want a dog
I want a dragon right one flying dog
will attack no I really would like it's
enough I'll work on getting you you
don't have mystical powers for ten years
[ __ ]
so listen listen if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to our channel
only if you want to if you want to no
pressure here I can do it
and veronica's - no pressure she has her
own channel no pressure no pressure
we're gonna do some shout outs here
amaryllis I don't know why getting a
shout-out is so important to me but I
[ __ ] want one
Cameron Owens you deserve one man you
worked hard to get this shout out you
won the Japanese masturbation contest
congratulations my friend you jerked off
and came the fastest way hmm you never
seemed like those Japanese games like
that
Oh one time I saw this Japanese game
that was like there's a bunch of guys
you can't see their faces it's kind of
like glory hole situation and then all
these girls are sucking their dicks and
then whoever it comes to fastest the
first wins a real thing this is a real
thing yes some HBO special oh my god
seriously yeah I'm like dead serious
are you just no I'm not that creative
you won that competition my friend the
jacking off one not this game suck dick
won so graduation that's how you got
this shout-out because you held in your
come for a month good job Bryce bed son
hey Ryan
I've been watching your channel for
months you make everything
funny and you're a great guy you don't
know that I could be a total [ __ ] in
real life you think I could have a
shout-out sure Bryce sure sure he goes
to bed when the Sun comes up it's called
bed son
that's a really cool last name yeah dude
you could totally have this shadow I
want you to take this shadow but don't
call me a great guy you don't know me
man I'm a horrible person in real life
he really is I know they mmm degrading
to people sexist I don't know why I hang
out with him I don't know why all these
females hang out with me all they do is
yell at me off screen it's really weird
I'm not someone you should look up to I
think you get a lot of [ __ ] a ton of
[ __ ]
this guy gets so much [ __ ] it's
ridiculous how much [ __ ] I get it's
ridiculous so it's kind of cool being
mean I love me me I'm a great guy dragon
pen Toba hey Ryan and all the real
rejects I asked for a shout-out and I
think I never got one scenes last
December I was a fan of you guys are
super awesome super super awesome I love
your videos and all the woman on the
channel and a dude on the channel and
that man
she's he's okay are very breathy I must
be from another country keep up the
amazing work oh there he is
yeah he would the amazing work shout-out
please your number one fan Brian pentola
Sarah my number one fan I don't recall
hearing from you recently though how
come we don't ever talk no more you
don't even call no more and that Ryan
forgets the lyrics right here and whoa
no I want to hear you're going with this
Brian once dear to
who are you they know I've been hanging
out with this guy way too much